there's many ways to be known and
Ferguson says it should be successful
and it's about picking their way to fit
you you got to think outside the box
mm-hmm because that's the only way
you're going to get out people around me
they don't see the more that you mate so
they don't tell you everything that you
should've did coulda did but it's not
funny or visit your get thrown out
you've got to always stick to your
vision no matter where he's an American
rapper singer songwriter and record
producer in February 2017 he became the
first artist to launch two albums
consecutively and have them go to number
one on the Billboard 200
he's also released several single
certified gold or higher by the RIAA
these future and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number two
is my personal favorite and I'm curious
if your grow which one you guys like the
best also guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired by your
sharing and also when you write it down
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself to enjoy
also a man mostly Phenom santak flights
into shows and get back on another
flight do a photo shoot do some
interviews not easily one and Ropin your
work because there's so many things
going on in your personal life the time
to get the sake is not being able to
deal with my kids as much as been around
my family so you got to always be driven
by your husband just could seem to cry
everyday not gonna be pretty everything
nice on these numbers so to speak
present you got to stay consistent and
stay productive every day you got to
work hard I was called the GU point on
in the studio and that's the Nez
Mountains where the music but you got
this love for it was something that you
think about you sleep and you dream and
you wake up and you breathe then you
want to live it there's so many options
is there's many ways to blow up as many
ways to be known and forget succession
to be successful and it's about kicking
that way to fit you man statistic said
if I did that not stopped going to
school and that's all I did was hanging
the hood that I wasn't going to be here
today
mm-hmm but that's why I still hang with
the same people that I was with back in
the hood and I changed my mentality I
don't think the same way I was when I
was there opened my mind up I thought
broader I thought outside of my horizons
like you got to think outside the box
because that's the only way you're gonna
get out when you're trapped in the trap
you really mentally trapped in the trap
and it's me me like man I want to make
sure my people just notice that's just
not the end of your life like if
somebody T statistics is not true you're
gonna fight statistics and go to the
next level like so six you said I
wouldn't even be here talking to you
right now if I were to listen to them
and tell them how my life would have
been they say one out of ten people they
gonna be like this one nine out of ten
black males that they do this live this
way they gonna do this you know I'm
saying there's no way around it they
gonna tell you is nowhere around so if
you ain't here right now you're standing
on a block every day then police is run
by that old lady that's looking at you
that's calling the police on you yes
the people who ran by just looking at
you like laying nests in your pants
saggin they think you ain't gonna never
be nothing they think you're gonna be
like that for the rest of your life like
who is the person to tell you that
you're gonna be standing on this block
all your life opposed to be a point in
your life where you only beer but you
get yourself a year to you from here you
don't do no good for you to be here all
your life and you're spending majority
of your life
22 hours I chose day trying to prove you
the harder than the hood you come from
the Jews born in is you when you came
home from the hospital you went to the
hood you know I'm saying so you don't
live your whole life this way for all
your life you deserve to live in a
different neighborhood better yourself
for 3-4 years out of your whole life
when you've been living this way
probably some dudes been living that way
for 20 years 23 years been in the hood
since they came home from from the house
building they still trying to prove to
the hood a hard day is in the end I'm
not making it because they didn't fool
today self you gotta prove yourself that
you want more than whatever hot off
everything I do our fish doubt them so
sometimes I get the free started and
play it back and come back and fix it
and make make it do way to do it but you
know I mean everything I've ever done a
first-time lot of people don't know that
but that's how I get made you know I
mean you just got to keep working that
into working working working work the
first one might not be right the
secondly the gentleman 15th when that
might not be right but you know I'm
saying you don't get it right you know I
mean you got to keep going and going
until you get it out and see what you
want to say at the end of the day when
out for my first song when I first made
my hair I knew what I could do you know
I'm saying I know the type of artist
that I am I know the caliber of music
that I can come with and I know I can
continue to do it I was born to make
music and when you got a gift for
something you just got to know how to
utilize it and when I found the way to
utilize that in our just make the most
of my opportunity I know I have to be
I'm hard as I have to stand the studio
and create all the time
you know I'm saying if I was to lay off
and I go to the studios and all those
he-said she-said it my Twitter came
through but I know the work that I was
putting in and just reinvent because
every album regardless having you gotta
reinvent yourself invention stuff so by
the time when
simplistic when they was rocking on like
the braids at throwback jersey they
already knew what he was going to next
time they was coming to hurry to knew he
wanted to do is he'll like this he all
he wanted to dress like this so the next
time you know he wanted to die on the
rap on his album I want to just straight
sing and do my production yeah I want to
rap on one dunno shows I want my every
chance every time you come and reinvent
yourself and get a fan something new I
know gay before the moment even with
other things we gave up on different
moments they might feel like there while
you made that move unlike many cities as
rats or if I gave it away I wrote it
why would you write a song like one
video song but you don't see my vision
for where I'm at right yeah you sing it
then when he was getting more money for
us over to me I felt like that did all
the work but I don't let that energy get
and where what I was doing but people
around me they don't see the movie that
you make so they don't tell you
everything that you should've did coulda
did but it's not part of your vision
you'll get thrown out you've got to
always stick to your vision no matter
what if you're already down one you
really kid you got to stick to that
vision you can't get here and get some
money on your life I want to change it
up enough because that's where you got
you guys you got to keep whatever guys
you just thank you says like we ever
been successful you don't know whiskey
keeps insisting happy how to be
consistent you know the right moves
you're making in every move that you
make English rather you just achieve it
something that you made clothes for
yourself if it goes in your cheek goes
at end of the day you steer sits down
this high when you reach the surf line
so I mean you know man I got to go to
that next level if you don't say
you want to be successful night people
for other people you know if you you
know life success for me just making
music necessary we're successful judges
are winning a Grammy front of me I
prostrated where's cold is filigree the
only here we so we you know those things
and go back in your mind and you should
be able to do those life free and free
or to negativity geometry of anything is
going to get in the way of hindering you
can get anywhere prosperity focus on the
media's all my photos on the great plays
and life our focus on everything I
overcome it could be in the person that
I am today I focus on the article our
focus on achieving our goals our focus
on shreemant live with no remorse and
want to create your own path you know
man even no matter what situation we're
rich poor whatever however is like if
you just want to be able to have you all
your own experiences in life great
experiences and listen and learn from
other people's mistakes so you don't
have to walk down to make the same
mistakes i was that some people just
heart and they want to explain mistakes
like i said they did it but um i just
create your own path and just do it your
way
everything that I'm living the way I
live is the way I wanted to live my life
it ain't somebody like then somebody my
family the way they was living I pretty
much create my own vow to create my own
create my path to create my my success
story you know I mean it my success
story it's not it's not the best success
story but any success story as long as
you got success it's cool you know I
mean you have to like bumps in the road
you got to get through you got mistakes
but for the most part you got to know
how to be able to maneuver and get
through it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jose Nunez asked
me to so the famous entrepreneur that
you I'm in a profile next leave it down
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know what his teachers
say that has the biggest impact on you
what video clip resonated the most with
you and what immediate action are you
going to take in your life or your
business after watching this video leave
it down in the comments below I'm super
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick chatter - Rajveer die max thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
sister see he got to give it to me today
even though I had all those wrinkles I
had on the timber because on the radio
and he's good and give me no awards no
nothing like I had love song who got a
good Christian alcohol then I wrote the
song for body party and I have how the
same down time which is never the end
with Kelly Rowland on the radio all at
the same time the Society's record
anything out our warranty went up for
water you like because it's like I'm
cheating it's like you like it's like
I've seen it like man taught you
there's no way you can audience record
so this is not going to give it to me
because this come to be easier to me
yeah so they're making me work to it
that's how I want it how do you do that
so how do you write a hit what is it
when I write so many songs I do 10 songs
a day and it just not every song the
same song but on all 10 do you have to
kind of write something it doesn't work
and then you get the exact number but
don't work sometimes I've never finished
it sometimes might just go first
sometimes it might just beautiful but I
just continue to work